retour en france avec l'environnement et
je vous le disais cette première grande
étude sur la pollution de l'eau par nos
médicaments antidépresseurs
antibiotiques pilule contraceptive on
l'a longtemps ignoré mais les résidus
sont bien présents dans les rivières
en fait les stations d'épuration ne sont
pas conçus pour les éliminer on n'en
mesure déjà les conséquences
enquête estelle colin alexis fischer un
principe actif dans l'eau c'est ce que
l'on attend d'un médicament prescrit
le problème c'est que des substances
chimiques circulent à votre insu via les
urines dans les égouts nous sommes à
l'hôpital militaire percy à clamart en
région parisienne ici des scientifiques
prélèvent 1,7 m sous terre un
échantillon des rejets il s'agit de
traquer les résidus médicamenteux
l'étude vient de commencer elle est
commandée par des fonds publics et
privés grand nombre également répartie
au cours de la journée et qui se
répartissent en fonction du débit ce qui
passe dans les bus 24 heures plus tard
l'échantillon arrive au laboratoire de
la faculté de pharmacie
ici on va établir la trace des molécules
présentes dans les eaux usées une
première en france
cette étude met en évidence la présence
de médicaments dans l'eau si vous avez
une personne qui consomme n médicaments
dont elle va pas polluer si vous avez
donc plusieurs milliers de personnes qui
consomment le même médicament
donc là on aura un risque d'avoir des
toners donc
non négligeable donc dans les autres sur
pas la réserve allemand est bien la
pilule contraceptive qu'est-ce qu'il ya
quand même beaucoup de femmes qui la
consomme effectivement dans l'eau du
robinet dans les grandes villes de
france
on trouve des traces de pilules
contraceptives certes infime mais avec
des conséquences pour la santé que l'on
ne maîtrise pas encore ce que l'on sait
en revanche c'est que dans les rivières
françaises
la population des poissons s'est
largement féminisé et que la
reproduction des espèces en trouve
altérée
face à la pollution les usines de
traitement des eaux s'affairent en
revanche ce qu'elles ne savent pas faire
c'est prendre en charge les résidus de
médicaments antibiotiques anticancéreux
antidépresseurs actuellement les normes
européennes
ni d'ailleurs aucune norme
internationale ne prend en compte ces
molécules médicamenteuses dans le
système de contrôle
donc on est encore dans le domaine du
développement de la recherche
et puis également de l'autosurveillance
faites par certaines certains
producteurs d'eau qui ont des
laboratoires de contrôle qui permet de
faire les analyses principaux
responsables de cette pollution nous le
grand public mais les industriels du
médicament on peut aussi une part de
responsabilité
et pour la première fois il le reconnaît
vraisemblablement longtemps on n'a pas
envisagé qu'il puisse y avoir des rejets
dans l'eau de médicaments aujourd'hui
tout le monde dont nous les industriels
acceptant le principe qu'ils puissent
avoir des rejets des médicaments dans
l'eau
des chercheurs ont récemment détectés en
mer du nord plus d'une dizaine de tonnes
d'acide chlorhydrique issues du
traitement anti-cholestérol toute la
chaîne alimentaire est concerné et
personne ne sait à ce jour en mesurer
les conséquences